sí
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález 39 millones
de colombianos estaban llamados a
participar en las elecciones
parlamentarias que estaban acompañadas
también de una consulta interpartidista
de tres coaliciones que buscaban definir
a sus candidatos para las elecciones
presidenciales que están previstas para
el mes de mayo estaban en juego 108
escaños en el senado y
188 para la cámara de representantes en
un país donde el congreso históricamente
ha sido de centroderecha las fuerzas
políticas de la izquierda bajo una
coalición llamada pacto histórico
repuntaron en cuanto a la cantidad de
curules en el senado pero todavía no
tienen mayoría lo que sí es cierto es
que marca el inicio de un nuevo capítulo
en la historia del legislativo
colombiano un capítulo que también
comienza con el retroceso del
oficialista partido centro democrático
que dominó la política colombiana en las
últimas décadas los ponemos en contexto
con el siguiente informe veamos
la primera cita electoral desde el
inicio de la pandemia en colombia deja a
la izquierda como clara vencedora la
coalición del pacto histórico liderada
por el ex alcalde de bogotá gustavo
petro irrumpió con fuerza en el congreso
de la república con 16 escaños en el
senado empata sin embargo con el
tradicional partido conservador ambos
seguidos de cerca por el liberal el
partido de gobierno el centro
democrático salió malherido de los
comicios el pacto histórico también se
hizo con 25 escaños en la cámara de
representantes
histórico
el mejor resultado
en la historia de la república
estamos ad portas
la presidencia de colombia me da
petro consolidó sus aspiraciones
presidenciales barriendo en la consulta
interpartidista de la izquierda con más
de 44 millones de votos la sorpresa sin
embargo fue francia márquez la feminista
y ambientalista afro obtuvo casi 800.000
votos superando incluso las votaciones
de los principales aspirantes en otras
coaliciones vamos
de la resistencia el poder hasta que la
dignidad
acostumbré a la derecha tampoco
sorprendió la victoria de federico
gutiérrez con más de 2 millones de votos
se plantó como la opción de la coalición
del conservador equipo por colombia
lucharemos para que en colombia no se
repliquen proyectos fallidos que muchos
de nuestros vecinos hoy justamente
padecen el candidato de centro sergio
fajardo obtuvo una votación muy por
debajo de sus rivales evidenciando la
fragmentación de su coalición centro
esperanza
[Música]
[Aplausos]
libre de las influencias no deben ser
parte de la política la polarización
sigue siendo la tónica en colombia y las
legislativas pueden marcar el rumbo de
lo que sucederá el próximo 29 de mayo
con las elecciones presidenciales
quedan muchas preguntas como por ejemplo
qué tan lista está colombia para tener
un congreso de izquierda para poder
obtener precisamente esa mayoría será
necesario que realicen algunas alianzas
con otras formaciones cuáles podrían ser
importante también destacar de esta
jornada electoral en colombia el
desempeño que tuvo la líder es a francia
márquez que fue la gran sorpresa de esta
jornada y también en las elecciones de
los tres candidatos que se van a
enfrentar en las presidenciales como lo
estábamos viendo en el informe como será
entonces el panorama para la primera
vuelta presidencial en este país
suramericano tras haber conquistado el
senado será que entonces la izquierda
ahora le apuesta al todo por el todo
para llegar a la presidencia sin
importar lo que tenga que pasar por
encima que tantos chances va a tener qué
papel jugarán entonces las formaciones
de centro y la derecha que
históricamente ha estado en el poder en
colombia y que llega a estos comicios un
poco debilitada víctima precisamente del
agotamiento ciudadano y también de un
poco de un sentimiento de decepción por
parte de los colombianos colombia
comienza a calentar motores ahora sí en
forma para las elecciones presidenciales
con temas transversales de fondo y temas
complicados la pandemia del cobi 19 que
continúa a avanzar en la implementación
del acuerdo de paz la crisis migratoria
los miles de venezolanos que cruzan la
frontera todos los días hacia colombia
el narcotráfico la inseguridad sobre
todo en esas zonas que son disputadas
entre bandas delincuenciales y los
cárteles de la droga sin duda alguna
colombia es un escenario muy particular
para un proceso electoral que busca como
siempre sucede en américa latina'
fortalecer la democracia hoy en el
debate de france 24 el análisis de la
pasada jornada electoral en colombia
podrá la izquierda conquistar la
presidencia de este país suramericano
para analizar este tema saludamos a
mónica pachón es ya doctora en ciencia
política y docente de la universidad de
los andes en la ciudad de bogotá en
colombia también está con nosotros
andrés segura él es consultor en asuntos
políticos y es socio de noia ambos están
en la capital colombiana les recuerdo
que ustedes también los televidentes
pueden participar en este debate con
todos sus comentarios y sus preguntas a
través de las redes sociales estamos en
facebook en instagram y en twitter
estamos como france24
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal les
recuerdo nuestra etiqueta es numeral del
debate efe 24 esperamos todos sus
comentarios e impresiones de esta
jornada electoral y como se perfilan ya
los candidatos para las presidenciales
en colombia comienza entonces con mónica
como les decía ya está en la ciudad de
bogotá en la capital colombiana
bienvenida al programa y quiero comenzar
como punto de partida del programa
haciendo un balance de lo que usted
concluye analiza de esta jornada
electoral parlamentaria y de esta
consulta interpartidista allí en
colombia
bueno pues muchísimas gracias por la
invitación quería contarles primero que
la jornada electoral fue relativamente
calmada acaba la oea de presentar su
informe de la misión internacional que
estuvo aquí en colombia hubo varias
misiones internacionales en el balance
baja participación más o menos el
47 por ciento de los ciudadanos salieron
a votar esta es un poquito más baja que
lo que hemos tenido en elecciones
inmediatamente anteriores tenemos un
panorama en el congreso muy muy parejo
entre los partidos que han tenido
representación en el senado con una
sorpresa obviamente el pacto histórico
teniendo una una representación
importante pero con una vida difícil
para quien llegue a la presidencia de la
república porque va a requerir hacer
unas coaliciones postelectorales como
que como bien decía se requieren muchos
sacrificios en las consultas obviamente
sale favorecido el candidato gustavo
petro soy con una
no muy grande sorpresa porque todos
sabíamos que iba a ganar y federico
gutiérrez desde la derecha y andrés
también le doy la bienvenida al programa
andrés segura también se encuentra en la
ciudad de bogotá bienvenido a andrés y
sus impresiones su balance de lo que
deja esta jornada electoral este fin de
semana en el colombia
cambiar muchas gracias por la invitación
tal como decía mónica creo que los
cambios estructurales están más al más
al lado del crecimiento de la izquierda
en colombia en términos de términos de
organización y en términos de peso en el
congreso los partidos tradicionales
mantienen su estabilidad y en quien se
de buena parte de su participación es el
partido de gobierno del centro
democrático y esto se manifiesta a la
gran fuerza que existe y que ha recogido
gustado petro para su campaña
presidencial que logró llevarla al
congreso con un impulso bastante fuerte
bajo desarrollando coalición de partidos
tórica y ahora vamos a ver si este
crecimiento
este crecimiento legislativo cómo va a
tener un impacto en las presidenciales
de marc andré de mónica continuó con
este análisis hablando del congreso de
cómo se reconfiguró el congreso
colombiano da un leve viraje hacia la
izquierda los partidos bajo el pacto
histórico irrumpieron con fuerza allí no
tienen mayoría tienen que hacer la
negociación como ustedes lo estaban
qué tan representativo es esto para la
política colombiana para la
consolidación de esa democracia
colombiana teniendo en cuenta la
historia de este país en donde la
izquierda y la derecha se han enfrentado
y ha llevado a que colombia tenga que
vivir un conflicto armado de más de
cinco décadas comienzo entonces con
andrés para hacer la ronda la inversa
la primera conclusión o primera
hipótesis que uno podría explicar es el
gran beso que tenía el conflicto y el
respeto que tenían las farc en el
crecimiento de la izquierda estas son
las primeras elecciones donde no son el
centro y creo que ahí se aprovecha las
aprovecha gustavo petro y el grupo que
lidera para
empezar a tomar un espacio que que tenía
pendiente desde hace décadas en colombia
ahora eso también tiene que ver mucho
con la presentación con el impacto y con
ella' con la coyuntura internacional
ante establecimiento y la búsqueda de
cambio y adicionalmente la coyuntura
post pandemia que hace que este ha
mostrado que buena parte del estado es
liberada en buena parte de este lado del
mundo no ha logrado darle respuestas a
la ciudadanía sobre necesidades básicas
y la crisis de pandemia
está tocando en toda la región la
canasta familiar y 2 y los ingresos de
las personas de una manera significativa
mónica la palabra ahora que se menciona
en los medios colombianos entre los
analistas es la coalición las alianzas
como pueden ser esas que se encaran ag
que se armen entre las diferentes fichas
que llegaron al senado y cómo podría
quedar configurado entonces la cámara
alta del congreso colombiano como lo ve
usted pues es muy interesante lo que
pasó porque había una expectativa de que
la derecha o que la izquierda que iba a
llegar con mucho poder al congreso en la
república con las coaliciones fruto
digamos de esta votación de estas
coaliciones y va a romper esta tradición
de que el congreso es fundamental para
la primera vuelta pero lo que resultó
que efectivamente vimos un congreso muy
fragmentado
en los que los partidos políticos que
conocemos entonces va a venir esta ola
de
negociaciones que es muy interesante
porque en colombia siempre existe un
gobierno de coalición postelectoral en
el caso de iván duque pues será el
partido conservador justas libres mira
el partido centro democrático y en
algunos casos con cambio radical una
coalición ahora lo que vamos a ver es
cómo se va a armar esa esa otra
coalición entonces en la izquierda
podemos tener el partido después el
pacto histórico ya con sus resultados y
se está pensando en esta negociación
entre el partido liberal y el pacto
histórico pero federico
el
candidato de la derecha
ha empezado ya a negociar y por ejemplo
el centro democrático de forma
unilateral
ayer aerio a la campaña adhirió a la
campaña de fico gutiérrez diciendo bueno
aquí nos unimos o nos morimos entonces
digamos que la lógica que colombia tenía
en términos de democracia se mantiene se
parece mucho a lo que ha pasado en los
últimos años en donde el presidente o
los candidatos a la presidencia no
tienen una mayoría clara en el comienzo
a pesar de la impopularidad de gustavo
petro llamar la atención mónica que
entonces el centro democrático se queda
sin un candidato propio para estos
comicios presidenciales ha sido un
partido que ha liderado la escena
política colombiana por lo menos en los
últimos 20 años y en estas elecciones de
congreso el partido pierde cinco
senadores pasa de 19 a 14
escaños en el parlamento qué es lo que
pasa con el partido centro democrático
que lideró o está a la cabeza el
expresidente álvaro uribe
muchos hablan ya de un descenso 1
y un agotamiento del discurso que
análisis hace usted mónica y esa misma
pregunta luego se la trasladó a andrés
para armar aquí diferentes opiniones al
respecto no es una gran pregunta quiero
aclararle a la audiencia que no quien
lidera la coalición quien es el más
importante la coalición es el presidente
o sea perdón en el uribismo es liderado
por álvaro uribe álvaro uribe fue
candidato independiente primero luego se
armó cambia un partido que se llama al
partido de la u cuando gana juan manuel
santos el karma al partido centro
democrático es decir
alvaro uribe velez ha navegado por
muchos partidos ha sido un independiente
porque él es muy poderoso en la política
colombiana pero realmente lo que
representa esto es efectivamente un
agotamiento de la figura de uribe como
eje divisorio y como como la persona que
organiza la política colombiana
eso es eso es radical digamos eso es ésa
es la diferencia que tenemos en esta
elección de las elecciones anteriores
por supuesto el tema de la paz se ve un
poco rezagado y digamos y ya lo dejamos
un poco en el pasado porque la propuesta
de gustavo petro lse es una propuesta
más antisistema como decía andrés una
propuesta más de democracia sustantiva
transformadora a la ola de las nuevas
digamos elecciones en américa latina y
entonces ese siente que el eje se ha
transformado desde ese desde ese mundo
al mundo no pro sistema y el mundo que
vamos en el que se propone el cambio
institucional más radical claro
andrés su opinión sobre esta
caída en cierto punto si se puede decir
así del centro democrático en el número
de curules o escaños allí en el en el
parlamento colombiano y sobre todo que
se quede sin un candidato de cara a las
presidenciales que le toca armarse de
valor y unirse a la candidatura de
federico gutiérrez que también es de la
derecha presenta los valores de la
derecha pero pues ya sabemos lo pesado
que era el centro democrático en la
política colombiana
pues primero para resaltar lo que apunta
a mónica creo que el decaimiento de la
figura de álvaro uribe es fundamental no
solamente para entender las elecciones
sino para explicar lo que ha pasado en
colombia en los últimos 20 años
y esto tiene que ver también con la
caída el
desprestigio que ha tenido el gobierno
duque como finalizando este periodo que
ha sido un golpe muy fuerte para este
para el partido político lo que no se
puede desconocer en este momento este en
centro democrático a pesar de sentir una
caída bastante importante terminó siendo
tiene una votación muy importante en el
congreso
que lo hace la cuarta quinta fuerza pero
con una diferencia de tres progresistas
en comparación dos o tres ya no me
acuerdo
16 tantos con el partido más votado y ya
sobre la presidencia buena parte del
lado del de la estructura política del
partido terminó siendo apoyo de federico
gutiérrez en este triunfo entonces al
final puede que la marca centro
democrático haya decaído
no se puede dar por perdido no se puede
dar por descontado el poder que pueden
tener en estas elecciones de alguna
manera otro en tallin para no dejar al
lado la
e2 lo viendo votación individual los dos
senadores más votados fueron de ese
partido entonces al final hay unos
pequeños liderazgos que pueden ir
creciendo
se destina un poco de la figura a álvaro
uribe pero es una tendencia principio
fuerte y no y ese apoyo federico
gutiérrez termina sido mucho más fuerte
de lo que uno podría pensar viéndolo
desde afuera andrés viéndolo
precisamente desde afuera viéndolo
precisamente fuera de las fronteras
colombianas uno puede ver que predomina
todavía la polarización colombiana entre
la sociedad colombiana y que este país
tal vez se encamina a un escenario muy
similar al de las elecciones pasadas
donde esto era blanco o negro esto era
izquierda y derecha para las
presidenciales el centro sigue sin ganar
fuerza en colombia porque
y creo que hay dos grandes razones la
primera el liderazgo no ha sido el mejor
en estos en estas últimas épocas y aquí
hablo en términos de show político por
así decirlo si estamos viendo que la
tendencia en el mundo es aprovechar
los diferentes mecanismos y las
herramientas de comunicación nuevas para
hacer nuevas formas políticas y llamar
la atención y crear grandes showmans
creo que los del centro no lo han
logrado y en estas elecciones
particularmente la división de
diferentes intereses y la de iu y
centrarse en la dinámica entre pequeños
líderes medianos que quieren hacer una
lucha entre ellos para ver quién va a
ser el líder creo que terminó matando
o debilitando para no ser tan radicales
la opción de centro n en estas
elecciones lo que no sucede por ejemplo
por la izquierda que ha logrado tener un
gran líder
logrado coordinar y articular diferentes
fuerzas de la izquierda del respecto o
lo que en su momento fue álvaro uribe en
colombia en los últimos años ya vamos a
hablar precisamente de los candidatos
que surgieron de esta consulta
interpartidista entre ellos está gustado
petro que fue uno de los protagonistas
de la jornada mónica pero también hubo
fenómenos más allá de la votación alta
que tuvo petro en el pacto histórico hay
personajes que llama la atención por
ejemplo francia márquez afrodescendiente
líder esa mujer en un país muy
conservador como es colombia sin
experiencia en cargos públicos tuvo
cerca de 700 82 mil votos con una
campaña de unos muy pocos meses que
representa esta mujer para la política
colombiana irrumpió sorpresivamente ha
sorprendido y es el análisis en este
momento de las personas que entienden
del tema político colombiano y la ven
como una especie de promesa electoral
puede ser visto así
a mí lo que me parece bueno quería
complementar un poquito lo que dijo
antes frente al centro colombia se
divide colombia es un sistema altamente
presidencial entonces el sistema
político colombiano se divide entre las
dos grupos que están a favor del
gobierno los grupos que están en contra
del gobierno hay unos partidos que se
declaran independientes entonces siempre
estamos polarizados en esas dos fuerzas
en esta en este caso el partido de
gobierno fue el centro democrático con
el partido conservador que no se nota
mucho y la fuerza contraria era el pacto
histórico porque gustavo petro siendo el
candidato que ganó la segunda votación
en 2018 estaba como jefe de la oposición
en el senado de la república ahora
francia márquez francia marca este es un
fenómeno interesante en colombia se ha
venido dando un movimiento de mujeres no
de feminismo digamos una agenda más
sustantiva inclusión en el congreso de
la república se ha perdido en tres veces
la oportunidad de pasar la paridad
formas electorales pero que pasamos una
una paridad mediana de candidatos en el
código electoral entonces hay un
movimiento naciente y francia- márquez
representa esa diversidad en su lugar de
origen como decían ustedes en la costa
pacífica su la representación del
movimiento social después de todos los
paros que tuvo colombia de toda la
crisis que vive esa esta región pues
francia márquez viene a representar eso
y por el otro lado pues es la pelea de
las mujeres al interior del pacto
histórico en donde gustavo petro ha
recibido muchísimas críticas por no
darle esa esa visibilidad a las mujeres
entonces muchas mujeres se volcaron a
votar por francia- márquez en una
digamos en una necesidad de escuchar la
voz de la mujer en la campaña que estuvo
muy ausente en en todas las en todas en
todos los espere espectros ideológicos
y así lo vemos de cara a las
presidenciales solamente hay una mujer
destacada de singles betancuria vamos a
hablar de los candidatos a la
presidencia y andrés le pregunto por
estos protagonistas de la jornada
mencionábamos ya francia market y
también mencionábamos a jonathan ferney
pulido que es un líder de la coalición
entre el centro esperanza y la alianza
verde
era un youtube con más de un millón de
seguidores en su canal de youtube y
logró irrumpir en la escena política
colombiana y ahora se va a desempeñar
como senador de la república
y fue la gran sorpresa en términos del
congreso terminó siendo la tercera gran
votación en el país de individualmente
un youtuber como de fuerza en
bucaramanga y en de origen de
bucaramanga una región cerca a la
frontera con venezuela la quinta sexta
ciudad en tamaño del país pero que tiene
unos comentarios políticos bastante
grandes y terminó liderando el la
coalición de centro para para el senado
terminó empatando superando por muy
pocos votos a humberto de la calle el
candidato presidencial y líder del
proceso de paz en colombia y sólo
estamos viendo como estos fenómenos si
están teniendo un impacto en la política
no creo que en el en el corto plazo que
iremos a tener un impacto a nivel
nacional pero en búsqueda de pequeños
escenarios sí tuvieron si lograron
capturar buenas buenas buenas votaciones
teniendo en cuenta además que este
personaje tuvo una un apoyo de otro
candidato presidencial otro personaje de
los que va a parecer el mayor que se
llama rodolfo hernández otro candidato
antisistema
y ya va a ser candidato no participó en
las consultas pero en las encuestas
generales que se decían previamente se
encontraba en el tercer lugar este apoyo
también de alguna manera ayudó a que
aquí el trabajo en digital tuviera un
resultado tan tan representativo
superando a muchos en votación a muchos
de los otros influenciadores o personas
que trabajan lo digital que también se
presentaron cuando les propongo que para
esta segunda parte del programa para
esta segunda mitad del programa nos
enfoquemos en el tema de las
presidenciales que es en lo que ya se
concentran los colombianos que llevan un
año hablando de elecciones
presidenciales y ahora sí por fin ven ya
esto en ruta 2 con unos personajes
claros y un panorama un poco más conciso
de lo que va a ser esa primera vuelta
análisis primero del panorama general
mónica de cómo vio usted entonces a
estos candidatos los tres que salieron
de la consulta interpartidista en total
son 10 mencionábamos que allí también
entra ingrid betancourt rodolfo
hernández que es un candidato
independiente de otras figuras pero los
más opcionados son los más sonados por
lo menos son estos tres que salió de las
consultas
ingrid betancourt y rodolfo hernández
bueno pues primero contarle a la
audiencia que en colombia hay digamos
mucha mucha participación de candidatos
independientes en colombia en esta
elección solamente se presentaron 40
movimientos
para para inscribir candidatos para las
elecciones presidenciales eso es una
locura y además están los candidatos de
partidos definitivamente los candidatos
que participaron en esta en esta
elección en las coaliciones para elegir
candidatos salieron muy fortalecidos
federico gutiérrez salió súper
fortalecido sergio fajardo como decía
andrés tiene un dilema de
liderazgo al interior de este movimiento
de hecho muchas de las personas del
partido verde en mi parecer van a entrar
al pacto histórico porque ellos les
dieron libertad entonces él está ahí
pues fue fuerte con un candidato tres de
tercera pero realmente ahí no tiene la
posibilidad
de crecer mucho frente a éstas a estos
dos polos y pues por supuesto ha gustado
petro los otros candidatos e ingrid se
inscriben muy tarde en la elección está
participando en los debates pero
realmente yo no le veo la capacidad de
competir
digamos en el corto plazo y crecer de la
forma que requeriría para hacer hacer su
elección competitiva para la segunda
vuelta aunque cualquier porcentaje en
este momento es importante y pues está
raúl fernández que es un candidato muy
regional que tenía una popularidad alta
pero al no participar en estas
elecciones y no tener congreso creo que
va a perder mucho poder entonces la
verdad lo que lo que yo creo es que la
elección va a girar en torno a tres
candidatos máximo y son estos tres
candidatos que vimos
en estas elecciones más recientes porque
contarse en elecciones es el primer paso
y ellos básicamente pasaron la primera
parte de la de la meta y los demás se
quedaron atrás creo pero pues andréis
puede diferir de lo que yo estoy
diciendo
andrés y cuál es su opinión su panorama
de estas presidenciales ya configuradas
con estos tres candidatos
creo que tienen silencio el micrófono
andrés entonces ya es hora sí
creo que yo sigo con la línea mónica
en este momento
la estamos todavía en la espuma que
generó la que generan las elecciones
legislativas no se puede olvidar que en
comparación a lo que pasó en 2018 falta
y se comparan con los que participaron
de la participación en primera vuelta en
2018 con los partidos que participaron
las resultas este domingo hay una
diferencia de 8 millones de personas
alrededor que que hacen falta por votar
y en este caso vamos a ver cuál es el
comportamiento de esas personas a dónde
voy con esto
las consultas le dan un turbo las
campañas los que verían en todos estos
meses
el a veces abel haberse medido les va a
dar un impulso bastante grande y a los
ganadores por supuesto y siguió la misma
línea de mónica creo que van a salir con
una gran ventaja pero no se puede pero
lo que sí va a pasar en las primeras
encuestas que seguramente saldrán la
próxima semana esta semana están en han
unas negociaciones para hacer las
inscripciones finales ahí lo que veremos
es que tanto se marcan esas diferencias
entre los demás los los porcentajes
general 2 que se veían entre las
diferencias creo que no se van a
mantener a ver un puntal a ninguna otra
espectativa de rodolfo que no sabemos
aquí aquí en pedazos se lo va a quitar y
eso es lo importante para realizar
andrés usted menciona una palabra que me
llama la atención esto le da turbo a las
elecciones le da un impulso a estos
candidatos y si hay un candidato que
tiene el acelerador puesto es gustavo
petro 4.4 millones de votos en solitario
en esta consulta interpartidista cómo
llega entonces gustavo petro el
candidato que representa los valores de
izquierda toda está el pacto histórico
que es una coalición de partidos de
staten de como llega entonces a esta
primera ronda mira llega muy fortalecido
llega con la idea de que es el candidato
viable y al final eso le da le quita
posibilidad los otros que vayan a llegar
porque ya es ante alguna pregunta
eventual sobre 15 usted que va a ganar
la respuesta a todo el mundo la vez a la
gran mayoría de los colombianos va a ser
gustavo petro si las voces que
numéricamente le hacen falta alrededor
de unos 4 millones de votos para ganar
en primera vuelta y ese es su objetivo
de alguna manera entonces vamos a ver el
cómo logra potenciar esa idea de que él
ya es el ganador él necesita para para
enseñar sin nada para ganar para el
ganar más confianza con mayor con mayor
facilidad es tener una votación muy alta
en primera vuelta porque ya en segunda
vuelta el alto negativo que siempre han
tenido dentro del lugar en contra y
puede pasar lo mismo que en 2018
mónica su opinión sobre este candidato
lo que representa a él para la historia
colombiana y para a la izquierda de este
país
gustavo petro es un político profesional
he estado en la en el ruedo político
desde los 90 ha sido un congresista muy
reconocido en los años 2000 fue una gran
oposición a todo el fenómeno paramilitar
en colombia y ha sido siempre una voz
disidente digamos en el sistema político
colombiano pero ha pertenecido al
sistema político colombiano durante más
de 20 años yo creo que su voz es
importante yo creo que la voz de la
izquierda y luego el proceso de paz es
una voz que se tiene que escuchar y por
supuesto es una voz que representa a
estas voces de inconformidad que se
dieron a partir de las movilizaciones
sociales en colombia en 2019 2020 y
luego con la pendencia por supuesto la
crisis económica hace que ésta que estas
necesidades se representen más en un
candidato de izquierda que claro un
candidato o parte del status quo me
quedan pocos minutos para finalizar el
programa quiero que hablemos también
federico gutiérrez y sergio fajardo
mónica y federico gutiérrez en poco más
de 2 millones de votos en esta consulta
representa a esta coalición de derecha
recibió el apoyo ya como lo decíamos del
centro democrático tal vez su reto más
difícil a lo largo de lo que le queda de
campaña es desmarcarse del presidente
educa que no tiene mucha popularidad
entre los colombianos y desmarcarse un
poco del uribismo y mostrarse como una
derecha diferente qué análisis hace
usted y yo creo que él es un candidato
muy hábil ahí hay un hecho en la
política colombiana y es que en la
primera vuelta uno puede ganar pero no
puede perder en la segunda vuelta y eso
significa algo importante en colombia y
es que la habilidad que él requiere es
el de unir gente
y hacer que esta unión efectivamente
represente más del 51 por ciento de los
votantes se tiene que desmarcar del
uribismo y yo creo que el uribismo tiene
claro eso entonces ha jugado un papel
muy marginal en silencio tratan de
apoyar pero no es una
apoyo de fotos o es un apoyo de imágenes
es un apoyo más
unilateral sí y creo que eso es lo que
él necesita para poder
acercar votantes de centro y también a
explicitar de una forma muy evidente lo
hacen los debates quiénes gustavo petro
quien fue gustado pet andrés lejos de
entonces el análisis de sergio fajardo
del centro un candidato que representa
unos valores distintos a la izquierda a
la derecha en que tanto puede arrastrar
para esta primera vuelta como llega este
candidato del centro a esta primera
ronda
llega debilitado llegue golpeado la
votación de la consulta fue menor a lo
esperado tiene la posibilidad de más en
un escenario donde puede ser una campaña
hostil donde puede ser una campaña
basada en negativos que es lo que ya
mostraba en estos dos días tiene la
posibilidad de mostrar un tipo de
campaña diferente para marcar y hablar
de la esperanza que es el mensaje que
que ellos quieren posicionar por lo
demás la posibilidad de ampliar el
espectro queda dado por su habilidad
política
y sobre todo de encantar a las personas
porque lo que vamos a ver cómo está
hablando mónica esto federico gutiérrez
va a estar buscando capturar el centro
basándose en la viabilidad de la campaña
de federico y en el
hastío frente a la posibilidad de una
izquierda y gustavo petro ahora lo hará
lo propio por cerrar ese cerco para el
centro sobre la sobre el miedo al
continuismo con uribe esa esa relación
es la relación esas fuerzas
balance real el margen de maniobra hasta
ser fajardo el cual le toca un mientras
que tiene y sobre eso empezará a crecer
empezará a crecer con un mensaje
diferencial la cocina en el instrumento
la unión ha sido complicada andrés y a
mónica des agradezco por haber estado
con nosotros esto apenas está comenzando
comienza entonces de forma oficial
digámoslo así esta candidatura a la
presidencia de colombia vamos a seguir
paso a paso lo que sucede allí en este
país suramericano les agradezco por este
análisis para la audiencia de france 24
y ustedes sigan en sintonía de france 24
y mucho más para ver
[Música]